We can think of a spectrum of similarity. At one end of the spectrum,
the target problem and the source case are identical.
At the other extreme end of the similarity spectrum, the target problem and
the source case have nothing in common. We can evaluate the similarity between
the target problem and source case in similar dimensions. In terms of
the relationships occurring in the source case and the target problem.
In terms of the objects occurring between the two. In terms of the features of
the objects and in terms of the values that the features of the objects take.
At the end of the spectrum, where the target problem and
the source case are very similar, with relationships, objects, features, and
values are all similar. At the other end the values, features and
objects may be different, but the relationships are similar.
If the relationships too are different, then there'll be nothing in common with
the target problem in the source case. When the relationships, objects,
features and values are all similar, then that is an example of recording cases,
and we have come across it. An example of that was from the colored blocks in
the blocks world. When the similarity between the target problem and
the source case is along the dimension to relationships and objects, but not
along the dimensions of values or values and features, then that's an example of
case-based reasoning. We discuss this method in the domain of navigation and
urban areas. The objects of the concept between the target problem and
the source case being the same means that the domains are the same.
So cased-based reasoning is within domain analogy. An analogical reasoning in
general, objects in the target column and the source case too,
might be different. We saw an example of analogical reasoning in the Dunker
radiation problem, when we were talking about cross-domain analogical transfer.
Actually recording cases in case based reasoning are also examples of
analogical reasoning, except that they occur in the same domain.
The target firm and the source cases in the same domain,
which is why we consider them earlier. By analogical reasoning here,
we mean cross domain analogical transfer. As in the Dunker radiation problem.